well I am we seem to be introducing
ourselves by we're in Harvard we reside
I think the for this for purposes here
the best identification is that I'm with
the Weatherhead Center which is an
incubator of many things and including
this and allows people to mix and match
across disciplines in a way that is been
highly productive for me as you can see
I've included Steve block as my
co-author and I also misspelled his name
my hates to give my slider hey Steve
don't take it personally I even smell
lots of things and steve is an economist
from from Tufts and in the in the set of
the Weatherhead Center that works so
this was this work on the social
sciences of the food has been supported
and sponsored within that within that
setting now my own work is on developing
areas and on agriculture and within the
developing world i specialize in the
study of africa which is as you know a
place where the challenges of nutrition
are extremely extremely high and in the
early years right after independence
when i was teaching at the California
Institute of Technology I got interested
in what was called at the time Africa's
poor start and by poor start I mean that
it would had stumbled out of the gate it
had 75 over seventy percent about 75% an
average actually of the population
living in rural areas and engaged in
farming and yet it was not it was with
starvation and there were importation
and the population was sustained by
importing food from abroad so why this
why this failure this fundamental
failure of performance of economic
perform
in Africa and on this led me to line of
work which looked at the political roots
of it and the political roots seemed you
wise is not going forward okay seem to
indicate that the incentives for
politicians were such that they were
adopting policies politically winning
policies that sustained them in power
that were suppressing markets that were
providing incentives for food production
in Africa there were on the consumer on
in terms of food purchasing there were
monopolies or monopolies that were
forcing farmers to sing to to market
through a single channel controlled by
the government that maintain low prices
so as to maintain afford affordable food
for urban constituents and and the end
the firm's themselves were selling their
goods at high prices because the firm's
were tended to be monopolies many of
them government owned and of course the
farmers with the primary with seventy
percent of the people in agriculture the
farmers with the majority of consumers
so they were being charged high prices
on the one side and be offered low
prices on the other which meant that
their profits were driven down and their
incentives to farm were driven down and
to produce were driven down now the
question is why then I tried to figure
out what and this was work that I was
doing unknowingly to either one of us in
parallel with the World Bank Elliott
Berg was doing research of the word back
collecting evidence I was doing research
as an individual scholar collecting
evidence and we independently came up
with the same they say the same findings
which increased our confidence in what
we were seeing our interpretation quite
quite a bit well then the question comes
why I do this dumb thing
why ruin the fundamentals of your
economy these are growing economies why
destroy them why distance what and and
and the answer was the nature of the
institutions led to these choices of
policies and in the following manner
most of the African society governments
at this time we're authoritarian these
are single party systems these are
military governments and personal
dictatorships less than a third of them
had competitive political parties
seventy percent or more had
authoritarian governments and in
authoritarian regimes their citizens get
represented the interests of citizens
get represented but they get represented
in the very biased way the urban sector
consists of a few large firms each one
highly large in these very small markets
and livings cheek-by-jowl in the
industrial parks that are outside
Nairobi and legos and everywhere other
places so they are economically
concentrated than they're politically
concentrated being economically
concentrated the firm will will demand
that the government give it give it
access to raw materials at a low price
or will join with the workers and saying
we want to have low wages because sixty
percent of their expenditures are on
salaries and they don't want strikes and
so they're lobbying for this kind of
these kinds of price distortions that
undermine incentives for farmers and so
they demand these policies they can
organize and support of the policies
because they live close together because
many of them are government-owned they
have access to the ministries and so
they're highly so representation takes
place in an interest group mode and the
firm's thrive in that kind of political
institutional environment the farmers
however each farmer is tiny if he
lobbies for something the costs of
lobbying will exceed the benefits to his
human his family and they're also
dispersed all over the place so low
incentives to lobby
high costs of lobbying the farmers even
though there were numerical majority are
a silent majority and the result is you
get this shift of relative prices
against agriculture so that was the work
I did them what's happened in the
meantime Africa has all of a sudden
become I started to grow whoops and and
and and and it one of the reasons it is
grown and this is the work Steven I have
done is because productivity is
increased greatly in the largest single
sector which is agriculture why is
productivity increased greatly because
these policies have been no longer
prevail in many countries why is that
it's because the nature of the political
institutions has changed we now have in
Africa competitive party systems in a
competitive party system politics has
dominated not by interest groups but by
party competition and parties wanting
majorities to win elections find most of
the votes in the rural areas seventy
percent of the people on negra culture
so the farmers that were disempowered
under interest group politics are
empowered under party politics and this
is Steven my Steven my my research
indicates that this is one of the
reasons that you've gotten this surge of
growth in the African miracle in the in
the last several years yeah